all right I got good news my friends we
got this uh this uh series of tweets
from John Nicosia he tweeted on October
11th cryptically scoop another big name
about to exit CNN Discovery executive he
does not have a place in the new CNN he
reminds us of the Zucker period we are
looking to move far from the only reason
he is still on the air was not to look
like we were cleaning house for
political reasons right after the
closing John says I agreed not to report
the name until the end of the week
the person this discovery executive was
talking about is Jim Acosta CNN like
they did when I reported about stelter
being let go will be uh will be to
defend will be to defend the person
that's what the network PR people do
keep in mind many of the recent people
let go had big support within the
network and more
but did not fit into the middle ground
Vision CNN is being pushed into since
Acosta was the was the main Trump
lightning rod between the old CNN and
the new owner's Future Vision he will
either go quick or with a lot of
internal pushback stay tuned one
important thing that this executive
wanted to stress is they are nowhere
near done and Acosta won't be the last
of the Old Guard to go but this takes
time and they're getting an incredible
amount of internal pushback from people
who want to stay a resistance Network oh
I love that quote a resistance Network
here's what I think is happening I think
that the executive is leaking to John
with approval from the company really
because they can't come out and
disparage the employees people like
Acosta probably for contractual reasons
but they desperately want people like
our audience to know they are cleaning
house and trying to to fix this problem
so here is exactly how you do it
I just think that there's any saving CNN
at this point and also who is worse Jim
Acosta or Brian stelter oh Jim Acosta I
think so yeah but they're both bad for
different reasons there's no saving CNN
sorry guys uh uh you know look I know
there's a lot of people over at CNN that
are thinking they can clean this up you
can't it's like you know when when you
get skunked it's like you you smell
lingers maybe CNN you can take a bath in
some tomato soup or whatever it is
you're supposed to do I don't know but
it ain't coming off it's it's really
stuck in there you know actually here's
a better example you ever you ever see
an apartment after like some old person
dies but they were a smoker since they
were 20. and everything is just caked in
nicotine and it's yellow that's CNN
right now so look by the time you gut
and Rehab the place it's a total it's a
total rehab it's not even gonna look
like CNN anymore you might as well just
call it something different and built it
from the ground up well they probably
will do that and also if they raise the
new generation knowing that that's new
Norm then CNN's not going to seem so
radical or crazy or biased and so if
they grow up in that smoke uh tattered
house they're gonna say oh this is
reality this is normal for us yeah it's
normal when your teachers are yeah right
into your face yeah that's that's how I
view CNN basically and and it's not like
they had a good record beforehand I mean
they were started by Ted Turner who of
course is a known eugenicist that I also
believe that there was too many people
in this world he of course was using the
network to push his agenda and you know
Linda you say should they be saved
absolutely not well no no no let them
wither away and and and no no no no no
no let them ride off peacefully into the
sunset with smiles on their faces I hope
that in Jim acosta's retirement he lives
a long healthy happy life and it won't
matter because he's not on TV anymore
bye-bye did you see Cuomo's new show
ratings were like forty thousand yeah
CNN lost uh this is according to Forbes
70 of their key demo within the last few
months Jesus I did not ask him CNN
should be saved I asked if it could be
saved I don't think it should be saved
and I think Tim's right their reputation
is way too far gone but I respect if
maybe they want to like change their
name and kind of go in like a completely
different direction like retire for two
years NCC
news for cable channels yeah we're sorry
News Network we're destroying this
country trustworthy sources yeah I was I
was always uh on our knees apologizing
please forgive us I was always a bit
partial to the cable channel name msnbs
you know because because if they did
that that I'd be that'd be pretty funny
and I bet you know they're kind of
owning it so uh you know I watch because
then when they come out and they're just
saying things like it's very
presidential of the president to bomb
another country and it just says msmbs
underneath them I'd be like oh checks
out yeah msnbs I actually would
appreciate that level of self-awareness
from a news site I think that would be
cool they should just uh brand
themselves as like uh State media just
go straight for like what it is yeah
American Pravda yeah that has a nice
ring to it too you know yeah didn't uh
Elon Musk buy the website American
Pravda and then he never did anything
with it did he really yeah he did he
sounds like something James O'Keefe
would buy is that his book yeah that is
his book yeah yeah but uh Elon Musk
bought the site and just never did
anything with it not yet not yet it's
been like six years though so hopefully
he does he seems like a pretty busy guy
huh what's it gonna do
I don't know man CNN is going down in
flames it's kind of a good thing Cuomo
tried launching a new shows at news
nation and then just nobody watches
they're just the it's not so much Old
Guard it's just kind of like
it's hard to build up a big show these
days period let alone being really awful
people that are obviously lying to you
you know like if you go on TV every day
and you're just like Sky's green because
uh it is good luck people are just gonna
be like why would I watch this so you've
already got people they can choose any
news network they want they can choose
any YouTube video they want and then you
add on top of it that you're a bunch of
really awful partisans who are lying
relentlessly it's no wonder their key
demo viewerships in the gutter and
unfortunately it's kind of no wonder why
they're 60s with 67 plus age bracket is
actually still fairly High it is low but
I feel bad for those people who
genuinely think CNN is news
maybe they can keep CNN but like make it
mean something different
like uh corporate non-news
like uh not news yeah they could switch
over and do the MSNBC where they're like
the American cheese product of news
networks where they're not actually news
their only opinion then they could
slowly shift to more moderate take
that's what they were trying to do yeah
yeah didn't work so what replaces it
what you know if people aren't getting
their their their uh the narrative if
people are well I'll put it this way
there's no unified culture anymore as I
often say we used to watch a handful of
news channels a handful we had we had
like five networks and that's why
everybody believed the same thing now
you've got all different channels all
different shows people can watch whoever
they want so everyone's going to be
thinking completely different things and
then where does where does that bring us
to what's the end result of that CNN
plus it's a crazy idea guys but I think
if CNN decentralizes and and does online
content for paid subscription I think
they're going to have a great success
with it they should try it what if
they're sacrificing CNN and closing it
essentially to like boost MSNBC or
something because you know how all the
audience is so deluded down over all the
the liberal media choices but fox is
doing so well in Leeds and all this
because there's only the one maybe
they're trying to just consolidate that
down
um there's not enough people watching
television in the classic way anymore
they'd have to get rid of ABC NBC CBS et
cetera et cetera you know yeah but
actually it would be really cool like
they're talking about firing Jim
CNN hear me out I got a big idea this
will be huge it'd be huge huge news shut
down just no more CNN gone let the brand
Sunset and then everyone can leave and
uh you know well they could keep their
International versions like because
other people in other countries don't
have the tainted opinion of CNN no just
let it go let's do that I mean CNN's
like they're pretty much almost dead
already no one's really watching them so
we should hold them memorial service for
them just like a mock comedic one where
like it was and we we go around the room
say our favorite moments that we had
with CNN mine was when the BLM
protesters were trying to burn down
their offices when they were talking
about great the protests were that's my
favorite uh if you guys want to go
around the table uh feel free to tell us
your favorite memory of your News
Network I felt like that was so fitting
that they went right up to their
doorstep and they were like we're
ruining it to you here we go my favorite
one of my favorite moments
um man this brings back memories you
guys you know I remember when there was
this viral meme of Anderson Cooper Waist
Deep in water
and then the the wide shot shows a guy
standing on the road in Anderson's just
like in the water for no reason
is like oh so much wind and water that
was definitely like a formative memory
of going oh all right this guy's full of
[ __ ] right fake news yeah but they win
an award you know yeah there's more
there's more there's Don Lemon in the
black hole come on I know you guys have
some come on come on you're right let me
let me let me do this one there was oh
man you guys the memories this was uh
Don Lemon was doing a panel the
Malaysian Airline went missing this is
this is an example of like why CNN
became what it is why did CNN go hyper
partisan because when the Malaysian
airplane went missing they didn't know
what to do so they had Round the Clock
coverage of a plane that was missing and
it was just re like people watched it
and then Don Lemon is talking to a group
of people and he says now we're getting
a lot of questions about you know black
holes and I I know it's Preposterous but
Mary is it Preposterous and then someone
goes you know even a small black hole
would swallow the whole universe so and
I was like wow the small one would eat
the whole universe I didn't realize
there must not be a supermassive black
hole at the center of the Milky Way
galaxy we were wrong about that and that
was mainstream news and it was funny
because when I called it out and a lot
people kept saying Yeah but come on Tim
he's just he's just making a show and
I'm like this is the most trusted name
in news asking a guest and the guests
spewing out the most insane garbage ever
ah that was that one was great I
actually remember where I was when that
happened that's how core it was to me my
personal favorite that we're all for
getting is actually fiery but mostly
peaceful that was CNN
yep I wasn't sure
yeah and then all those all those uh
wonderful memories from New Year's yeah
oh yeah when they all got drunk and
accidentally told the truth that was
really fun too right
there's Russia gate those guys oh man
wow there's you know calling Trump a
Nazi for like four years that was that
was incredible what a brave that was
bold what was it like 60 000 times or
something Trump sued and they said that
they called him Hitler like tens of
thousands what was that discredited
lawyer that they propped up so it was
gonna be the next leader of the
democratic party yeah us just old
friends laughing about the old times and
you know I'm gonna miss them so CNN's
probably just gonna Rebrand or shift all
their leadership and whoever controls it
yeah what are they shifting over to is
it well they brought in a new guy
Discovery bottom I guess and they got
this uh what's his name Chris Licht is
that who's doing it great last name by
the way and they're firing all of the
crackpots okay
I want to tell you guys one of my
favorite moments it was when they fired
Brian stelter oh yeah and Don Lemon yeah
yeah well Don lemon's got moved to a
Morning Show yeah he got demoted my
favorite Don Lemon moment was when he
tried really hard to pin that most
recent hurricane on global warming and
the NOAA guy was like yeah no that was
not a real thing I had personal
experience how can we forget the
incredible Lubin tubing
come on guys you're right come on you're
right seriously that's a good one is
this one is this what it's actually like
like after the funeral when everyone's
remembering the good times they have
absolutely like I remember you know you
know Jimmy he threw me a beer and that
and I didn't know I never realized it'd
be the last beer he threw me and now
we're just like oh CNN they made up fake
news that one time and it's the last
time we're ever gonna hear it yeah I
mean we're being awfully generous for a
funeral of like a piece of [ __ ]
yeah I think that um you could easily
say that my favorite part about CNN was
their titling reliable sources from the
most trusted name in news there's also a
show called like No Lie by some guy who
totally makes stuff up I'm like this is
totally the reliable sources that's how
Brian Setter leaves I love how just like
they're so obvious with what they're
doing this show is called the only true
show with facts and we're Fair on the
most trusted News Channel that's right
we should we got to do that with Tim
cast we got we got to call we gotta make
a tagline like the only honest factual
reporting anywhere ever from the most
trusted name in news and commentary that
is fair and balanced
that's good what's msnbc's tagline
lady going nuts
there's so many more moments coming up
that I just have to bring up especially
with the doctor that that went on The
Joe Rogan show and then and then said
that Joe first originally he said Joe
Rogan was taking horse Pace went on The
Joe Rogan show he said he wasn't taking
horse pace and then Don Lemon bullied
him to say he was taking horse Pace
again so Sanjay Gupta that doctor oh
when they hit the brain how can we
forget about that one oh my goodness oh
man the memories you guys oh my God so
uh they're all coming do you know about
this one no the cannibal CNN reporter
that sounds oh yeah
Aslan
he's like a religious scholar and
commentator had a show and he ate a
piece of human brain right right he went
to uh there's another country like yeah
India I think okay I think I thought it
was a tribe in afghanist like a super
isolated tribe I thought it was India
yeah it was Hindu yeah and he sat down
and they cooked a piece of brain and he
ate it and I think I I think he went
insane from it I really do you got Kuru
is that what it's called yeah yeah the
shakes you eat the shakes yeah you eat a
human brain did it get smarter no no
oh no I think you know I I think it's
psychologically destroyed him
probably yeah it's like something that
you do in the moment and then later you
go holy [ __ ] well well so but here's why
this is around the time that Vice was
presumably big everybody thought Vice
was like the biggest thing ever and they
really wanted to emulate this and so
they CNN tried making this very
vice-like show and they're like we're
gonna send this guy this religious guy
to go explore these religions and he's
gonna eat brain and he probably felt
like he had to do it yeah he's sitting
there in the moment the producers are
like eat the brain eat it then we're
gonna get all the ratings and he's like
and then he eats it and then he's like I
did it are you happy and then they
canceled this show and so I can imagine
he's like sitting in his living room and
he's like looking at his hands and he's
like
[Music]
that's who he is now he's a cannibal by
the way yeah yeah I've had I've had
people tell me that Reza aslan's not a
cannibal and then I was like what's a
cannibal
it's a it's a human who ate who eats
human right yeah and then I had someone
say to me he's not a cannibal he ate
human one time and I was like oh so if
someone murdered someone one time
they're not a murderer I mean if you
smoke crack once you're not a crackhead
your crackhead is a reference you're not
an addict but a crack a crackhead is a
reference someone who continually does
it right a murderer right oh yeah yeah
you're right he just murdered one guy he
only murdered one guy you know and and
so yeah you're a murderer then dude some
people have argued they're like if you
steal once are you a thief 10 years
later
and it's like good question you know
okay okay so maybe there will be a
certain point where he's no longer
accountable but that's up for personal
discretion as to when you feel he's no
longer in my personal opinion he still
is because he's still actively eating
human brains but I don't have any proof
he might be
just my opinion what if that's what the
reason he went crazy you guys ever see
uh was it iZombie you guys know that one
is it called iZombie is that the show no
idea it's a show yeah it's like it's
someone look it up there's like a woman
and then she gets bitten and then the
way the show works is that if you're if
you've been infected and you eat brains
you don't degrade into a Mindless zombie
you stay as like a conscious Lucid
zombie I guess what oh yeah you can see
part of this [ __ ] yeah is that the show
yeah it's called iZombie and I have to
say the favorite favorite thumbnail I
ever made was Reza ozon eats a brain
eats someone else's brain and loses his
own mind or something like he ate
someone else's own maybe like after that
moment I just want you to picture this
you know he's like he comes back he's
like he's he's he feels psychologically
traumatized from having done this but
the next day
the steak just doesn't taste the same oh
no yeah the candy bars don't have that
sweet Feeling Anymore the cheesecake
just no longer lingers and he starts
getting pale and he's like what's
happening to me and then he calls he
goes to a butcher and he's like let me
try the pork and he goes and he cooks it
doesn't work for him he's like maybe the
elk and then finally the guy goes hey
buddy
I know what you need I know what you
want I know what you need call my guy
here's the address and then he goes to
this address and he's like what is it he
looks up and it says New York City
Morgan he's like no
and then he goes in there and that's it
that's Russ's history dude this reminds
me of that it's always sunny episode
where they are tricked into eating
raccoons someone tells them it's you and
me and they're like oh my gosh I guess
we have to go to the morgue I think
that's what's going on they should have
done like the Army Hammer move and like
just have him go sell timeshares in the
Caribbean because once you're a known
cannibal I guess that's what you go do I
guess he's like super rich though anyway
so like I don't know if he really cares
but I have to be honest you know I was
like I I jokes aside I was thinking
about how he ate human brain and I was
just thinking like yo if it were me
and I did I would be destroyed because
that you can never return like there are
certain things in your life that you can
never undo and like forever he will have
been that guy who ate human brain I
think I would do it eat human brain yeah
just to try it in like a religious
ceremony you'll get Kuro is that what I
don't know like a religious ceremony
like that'd be kind of weird but that's
what it was you'll get the shakes thanks
for checking out this segment from the
timcast IRL podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
Monday through Friday at 8pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the timcast IRL podcast and
there's a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
Monday through Friday at 8pm and we'll
see you all there